E aí
[Música]
O Anthony Hopkins Daryl Hannah greta
thunberg aguento Miller eu que temos
assim como uma pista não é a conta
bancária são os autistas ou seja temos
um cérebro que funciona é diferente da
maioria de vocês muitos ainda não sabem
exatamente o que é autismo existem
diversos mitos acerca da condição que só
pioram esse desconhecimento
provavelmente ao longo da sua vida você
já escutou o várias coisas pejorativas
sobre autismo mas infelizmente o número
de pessoas que espalham preconceito e
desinformação é muito maior que o número
de pessoas que são dispostas a ensinar
sobre nós pessoas neurodivergentes
imagina em que o cérebro de vocês não
autistas é comandado por um sistema
operacional Windows bom eficiente faz o
que é necessário fazer todo mundo
conhece e usa aí temos a sexta no
sistema Linux aberto pronto para receber
milhões de informações mas que a maioria
das pessoas não conhece e tem medo o
autismo é uma diferença do
neurodesenvolvimento nós recebemos
processamos e respondemos a determinados
estímulos restore motores diferentes de
um autista podemos ser hipersensíveis a
barulhos e ao mesmo tempo ter uma
resistência à dor assombrosas cada
autista é único e possui características
diferentes não somente por conta da
condição mas também por influência do
ambiente da personalidade da cultura o
que nós autistas temos em comum e mesmo
assim de forma diversa também é o que
leva um especialista a nos diagnosticar
uma comunicação diferente da comunicação
dos notícias indo da ausência da língua
falada a uma verbalização distante do
grupo a notícia está inserido movimentos
repetitivos que chamamos carinhosamente
de extinção pois além de não celular
demonstra Nossa Alegria empolgação por
algo interesses restritos o famoso
hiperfoco Bautista vocês devem ter
percebido que a primeira coisa que eu
usei para explicar as pessoas autistas
foi mostrar o quanto somos diferentes
entre nós Mas isso não deveria ser
motivo para tanto estranhamento certo a
diversidade é uma dádiva da natureza e
espécie humana é campeã Nesse quesito
existem pessoas negras brancas amarelas
vermelhas altas baixas magras gordas
nascidas biologicamente em corpos
masculinos femininos e também tem sexo E
falando em sexo
e moramos séculos para descobrir que os
corpos de homens e mulheres são
totalmente diferentes não só nos órgãos
que designam sexo na verdade somos
diferentes níveis moleculares o coração
o pulmão os cães de mulheres têm
particularidades não existentes nos
órgãos de quem foi designado
biologicamente como menino ao nascer
vocês devem estar se perguntando mas o
que isso tem a ver com autismo Essa é a
segunda coisa que vocês devem saber
sobre o autismo não é uma condição
inerente mente masculina existe esse
mito de que as pessoas autistas são em
geral meninos daí a ideia é tão ridícula
da cor azul para marcar o dia dois de
abril conhecido por ser o dia da
conscientização do autismo só que
estudos estão mostrando cada vez mais
que existe um grande subir diagnóstico
de meninas as notícias além de muitos
muitos diagnósticos errados TDH Bipolar
é borderline
para explicar o porquê de tantas
mulheres se encontrarem hoje sem um
diagnóstico adequado de autismo Primeiro
vamos precisar analisar um pouco a
relação histórica das mulheres com a
ciência não sei se sabem mas até a
década de 90 a maioria dos ensaios
clínicos não utilizava mulheres e seus
grupos controle e isso significa que
aquela medicação para o coração que a
sua vó tomava todos os dias nunca tinha
sido testado em um corpo feminino nunca
a médica Paula Johns um trouxe dados
assombrosas de como a saúde da mulher
foi ignorada pela ciência por muitas
décadas da doença cardíaca a depressão
doenças comuns e mulheres e que nos
matam todos os dias os estudos clínicos
feitos para buscar tratamentos para
essas doenças
em sua maioria não utilizavam mulheres e
quando utilizavam ignoravam as
diferenças existentes se você aplica os
mesmos testes e protocolos em homens e
mulheres vai ter resultados enganosa
pois nossos órgãos reagem de forma
diferente Isso parece ser algo Óbvio
para nós atualmente mas é um pensamento
que só foi levado em consideração pela
ciência algumas décadas
estudos feitos pelo Governo dos Estados
Unidos mostram de oitenta por cento dos
medicamentos retirados no mercado o
foram por apresentarem efeitos
colaterais em mulheres isso porque se
medicamentos eram testado somente em
células masculinas
e existem diversas razões para isso
desde proteger as mulheres e os fetos de
serem alvos de estudos antiéticos até
baratear os custos a pesquisa em razão
das menores oscilações hormonais dos
corpos masculinos
lembram que eu disse antes que até
algumas Décadas atrás não se sabia das
Diferenças Profundas dos organismos
femininos e masculinos pois bem à saúde
da mulher era tema da ciência só no que
se referia aos órgãos reprodutivos útero
ovários sim realmente éramos éramos
Vista somente como reprodutoras
a hora se os corpos femininos foram
sistematicamente isolados dos Campos de
pesquisa espaço conhecimento sobre como
determinadas doenças ou condições
atingem a vida de nós mulheres ao redor
do mundo
sintomas diferentes para corpos
diferentes o que resulta em menos
diagnósticos mas se esses diagnósticos
não acontece claro que estudos de
prevalência serão distorcidos é aí que
está o problema
existem diferenças perceptiveis na forma
como autismo se manifesta em cérebros
femininos e masculinos no caso das
meninas autistas em geral temos melhor
habilidade comunicacional que os meninos
autistas interesses fixos mais comuns
com as meninas não autistas e o
principal sabemos emissoras mascaram o
mesmo que inconscientemente nossas
características autistas já os meninos
autistas costumam ter interesses bem a
ti é diferente de seus pares não
autistas além de maior dificuldade no
desenvolvimento de formas de comunicação
seja ela falada ou Por meios
alternativos
parece algo tipo de homem mas é ainda
mais exacerbado acreditem Judite Gold da
National autistic society diz que a
proporção Entre Meninos e Meninas seria
em torno de dois por um esse disparate
antes acreditava-se que a proporção era
de 10 puro tem como principais causas o
desprezo pela saúde da mulher como
relatei antes e a própria história do
autismo Graças aos erros no início das
pesquisas sobre o tema o autismo foi
visto por muitas décadas como algo
extremamente raro e Masculino só com a
descoberta dos estudos de asper na
década de 70 foi que começamos a
entender que somos Na verdade o espectro
com diversas formas de manifestação na
nossa com e a política mundial também
nos prejudicou a poucos anos vem à tona
o estudo de uma médica russa Bruna F
morna de 1926 realizado quase duas
décadas antes dos artigos desenvolvidos
no eixo ocidental e sua descrição sobre
as características das crianças que ela
acompanhou pasmem é muito semelhante ao
que temos hoje no manual
estadunidense de Diagnósticos mentais o
dsm-5 Mas agora você deve estar se
perguntando com autismo afeta
diariamente a vida de milhares de
garotas ao redor do mundo
e Imagine uma menina com seus três anos
em português tão perfeito que constrange
os adultos apontando os seus erros era
uma menina que vivia perguntando tudo E
sempre repeti nas mesmas perguntas não
era tão diferente dos meninos da sua
idade já que era apaixonada por animais
Qual o menino não é só era uma paixão um
pouco exagerada dizer a mãe já que seu
único interesse de passeio ela if
cavalgar para os domingos seus cadernos
passavam longe do Capricho das colegas
da sala e até a irmã mas consegui
escrever um texto de redação como se
adulta Já fosse essa menina foi
crescendo passou a ficar obcecado em
namoro como a maioria das adolescentes
ela andava falava e agia como as
heroínas dos livros que inocentemente
sua mãe me emprestava para ela muito
distraída diesel e não parecia viver no
mundo real pois seus semblantes
demonstrar você tá quase o tempo todo
mergulhado em seus próprios pensamentos
mas quando falava sobre o que gostava
parecia não conseguir se controlar como
falava e as mãos essas não paravam nunca
estavam sempre mexendo em algo tocando
superfície seus cabelos mãos inquietas
diesel e desajeitados como eram antes
enfeitadas essas mãos na verdade ainda
estão mas ela aprendeu a conviver com
isso tão inteligente mas tão chatinha
Dizer Mamãe e assim cresceu suas
diferenças eram quase imperceptíveis mas
fazia com que ela não tivesse muitos
amigos nem conseguisse arrumar um
namorado tão frágil emocionalmente ou
Manhosa chorava todas as vezes
precisava de um banho frio para acalmar
as crises de nervos que tinham noção de
risco zero
é essa menina cresceu e continua bem
gelada não entendi a intenção das outras
pessoas e por isso passou por situações
muito perigosas principalmente em
relação a homens foi assediada
sofrer um estupro na primeira vez que se
aventurou em uma viagem de excursão sem
a família já com 25 anos
essa menina não pensava em ter filhos
quando com quase 40 anos encontrou um
homem que se encantou com o seu jeito
diferente seu filho nasceu no mesmo mês
que ela completou 40 anos Três anos
depois ele foi diagnosticado autista e
quatro anos depois dele tem o seu
próprio diagnóstico Vejam o diagnóstico
do filho foi fácil ele ao contrário dela
tinha sinais bem clássicos não falava
até quase quatro anos seus steams ou
seja os movimentos circulatórios que
fazia com o balançar do corpo e das mãos
são bem comuns em crianças autistas e
claro o sexo masculino
tinha interesses bem restritos e
atípicos como tudo que se relacionava
luzes e distribuições Ele ama desastres
naturais e não naturais como o naufrágio
do Titanic
e tchau diagnóstico dela só aconteceu
após uma jornada sofrida por
especialistas que poucos sabem realmente
da condição se você se comunica muito
bem para ser autista de seu primeiro
psiquiatra que ela procurou 20 minutos
após ela entrar no consultório Você é
mulher o autismo é quatro vezes mais
comum em meninos apesar das suas
características serem sim semelhantes
autistas provavelmente seu problema é
afetivo você demonstra episódios de
agressividade então é bipolar disse o
neuropsicólogo
bem essa altura você já deve ter
imaginado que essa menina sou eu e
talvez estejam se perguntando o mesmo
que uma psiquiatra falou comigo mas você
se casou tem filho trabalha com
importância de um diagnóstico Nessa
altura da vida que prejuízos você teve
por ter essas características
bom e quando escuta essa pergunta me
recordo imediatamente de todas as vezes
que me sentir incompetente por ter
grandes dificuldades em amarrar os
sapatos ou qualquer atividade que
envolva a motricidade fina o de todas as
vezes que tive fortes crises emocionais
por não saber lidar com a quebra de
rotina ao ponto de bater a cabeça na
parede ou rasgar minha pele de tanto
coçar
de todos os Barões e quedas que ainda
tem por não conseguir perceber meu corpo
no espaço que ele ocupa já que tem teste
de própria acepção
e foram anos me sentindo inferior
insuficiente ou em capaz de fazer coisas
que eram demasiadamente simples para as
outras pessoas
Graças Principalmente ao não
entendimento de mim mesmo tem hoje
depressão transtorno de ansiedade e
síndrome do pânico Você sabia que a
principal causa de morte de autistas
grau 1 ou seja os antigos as perns ao
suicídio
e eu passei quase uma vida pensando em
me matar e só não fiz por conta da minha
religião
e talvez maior prejuízo que eu enfrentei
pela ausência do diagnóstico foi de não
conseguir enxergar as minhas qualidades
únicas que só existem por causa do
autismo
diferente do que muitos pensam o autismo
definissem porque o autismo permeia tudo
que sou penso e sinto eu não seria quem
sou se não fosse autista Isso não é um
problema uma sociedade excludente que
existe igualdade para acessar direitos
Isso sim é um problema mas tem solução
informação e menos preconceitos Graças
autismo eu sou capaz de ficar 12 horas
sem comer sem beber o banheiro só para
realizar uma atividade relacionada à meu
hiperfoco Aliás foi graças ao meu
diagnóstico que desisti de fazer algo
que eu detestaria entrar para um serviço
público administrativo e mudei de
carreira hoje sou adestradora e me sinto
uma criança no parque de diversão todo e
quando for atender os meus alunos
também é graças ao autismo estou hoje
aqui falando com vocês e isso já deveria
ser motivo para agradecer mesmo
se eu soubesse que era autista desde a
infância muita coisa seria diferente
hoje eu tenho criado estratégias
melhores para lidar com minhas crises
sobrecarga sensorial e social para me
prevenir melhor dos assédios e talvez só
talvez aquela viagem não teria terminado
de forma tão sofrida para mim eu não me
sentiria tão mal por ser quem sou e por
não conseguir me comunicar direito com
os lindos que conheci na vida ao invés
de ter hoje síndrome de pânico de
direção talvez eu tivesse mais paciência
com minha dificuldade em dirigir ou com
a de amarrar os sapatos e fazer compras
sozinha
a fazer compra em geral
vivo É como esse que sou fã muito antes
de virar modinha
O diagnóstico é norte e direcionamento
sem o diagnóstico eu e muitas outras
mulheres que conheciam esse caminho e
que tive o privilégio de ajudar
estaremos ainda no sentido incompetentes
desmotivados as e solitárias hoje
sabendo que Somos lindos podemos nos
comunicar melhor com os lindos é absurdo
tentar tratar o diferente como se
fossemos iguais
ignorar a diferença é tão cruel quanto
acreditar que seja diferente algo ruim
grande parte da minha trajetória seria
percorrida de forma mais fácil Se eu
soubesse desde a infância que eu sou uma
mulher autista E o que mais me preocupa
sobre a exclusão histórica das mulheres
em relação ao que se sabe sobre essa
condição é perceber em 2021 as coisas
não são muito diferentes nós mulheres
Ainda precisamos lutar insistir para o
diagnóstico correto
Com certeza você conhece uma mulher
autista que nem sabe que é autista ou
você mesmo seja essa mulher
escuta em
diagnóstico é libertação e já passou da
hora de reivindicar mos uma medicina que
também enxerga as mulheres incluindo o
nosso as altas obrigada
E aí